anyway um there's so many things I want
to talk about with Johnny I'm gonna
leave you guys got lots of track so we
suck no let me let me talk about this is
a story that I say all the time when you
and I go to the Bakersfield and I left
my truck in my in the parking lot at the
Comedy Store
oh yeah and we look up we see the ghost
yes thank you
yep yeah yeah well I thought it was a
man but you thought was an old lady but
you know I saw that dude a few times
that they call that I didn't know at the
time until one day they call him Gus Gus
yes yeah I just want to throw that up
because I say that story a lot about Gus
and the ghost mm-hm and no one ever
believed me
right but that's why and and just so
everybody understands when when when
Bobby and I saw this and when I and when
I saw what I thought was Gus and at some
dude in a trench coat with that with
that with the Derby yeah yeah hat in the
belly oh yeah yeah this is what I was
even a regular yet I was doing while I
was in a sketch group up in the belly
room that was when I was in Los abstract
O's with Freddie asparagus Wow
yeah in a sketch show yeah the sketch
group right Freddie a spirit you knew
Freddie a scarebear cos I worked with
Freddie as Merrill's okay if you don't
know who Freddie asparagus you'll the
only movie that you saw no person in a
movie called three amigos so he's the
bargain right so remember when something
happens and he comes up the people shoot
he is a famous line about the Lynam
but like that's ready asparagus but he
did okay he'd already done a lot of
films yeah but so what I want when I saw
who I end up later finding out that that
was guys at the time I didn't know just
like hey man I thought I saw some old
dude some older man in the trench coat
whatever cut to like literally 15 16
years later they bring those
poltergeist people into the store and
then it ends up on A&E right and I'm
watching it because I heard about it I
remember they were there so they're
talking about and all of a sudden the
lady is like yeah there's the hit man
for Bugsy carried a 45 snub or 38
snubnose he was the hit man
he took care of everybody he wore a
trench coat and a hat his name was Gus I
see this like 16 17 years later and I'm
sitting on my place when I just went
holy [ __ ] I've seen Gus that's the dude
I saw I saw one time and then I saw that
what I thought was a lady but yeah it
was it was Gus
what I saw was a top hat faceless man
top knot or a derby something I don't
know
you said you've never seen a ghost
wouldn't I say that he said he stopped
believing in ghosts
I believe believing believing is seeing
and believing is to differ so what do
you see is not believing because your
eyes can deceive you okay what do you
think it was that we both what do you
think we saw that night up in the top of
the that back room do you what every
right right right right right right was
like 3:30 I know I know I know
I believe it yeah III I know I see what
I see I believe what I believe and
that's end of the story okay
can we get that as like one of the
greatest quotes yeah I believe what
every American right now facts they're
not enough that's true yeah the fact I
believe what I believe but we live or
something we're seeing isn't really what
we're seeing because people are putting
[ __ ] together photos photoshopping so
you don't this this political guy is is
shaking hands with this believing you're
like really and then you find out later
that doesn't look real
[Music]